how do you dribble the time how do you
find the time to build a property
business whilst at a job I don't think
you have a choice if you get dedicated
to doing something and you're fully
committed to doing it you have to make
that time everybody's got 24 hours in a
day it's just about how you use them
hours it was difficult I bought a house
when I was over in America most
difficult house I've ever bought they
insisted on signatures from the
solicitors I wasn't in a country it was
an absolute nightmare it took a lot
longer than than was needed but we got
it there in the end you know if you want
something bad enough you have to commit
yourself you have to get done